[Musique]
valérie 69 1326 voir
[Applaudissements]
60,95 61 cette victoire est une bonne
nouvelle bonne nouvelle pour la
démocratie une bonne nouvelle peau débat
démocratique moi je préfère que ce soit
une fraction plus raisonnable des
républicains qu'il est emporté est ce
que la droite est prête dans sa
tradition à n'avoir aucune tête qui
dépasse mais derrière une femme bien
évidemment bien évidemment on est
derrière une candidate c'est simplement
parce que la candidate était la
meilleure je sais pas si elle va
récupérer une partie de notre électorat
l'accompagnent le dira mais ce que j'ai
vu pendant la primaire c'est une valérie
pécresse qui est tout sauf centriste
dans son discours en faisant radical
avait employé le terme extrême droitisée
c'est la manière dont une partie de
l'électorat des républicains s'est
radicalisée s'y retrouver dans les
propositions d'eric ciotti qui dans le
fond sont très proches c'est les
propositions qui sont très proches de
celles d'eric zemmour
eric ciotti auront toute leur place dans
ma quand justement valérie pécresse
c'est la candidate de la manif pour tous
c'est la candidate de droite mais d'une
droite qui je l'espère va revenir dans
le champ républicain parce que
clairement la primaire les débats qui a
eu dans la primaire les républicains
n'étaient pas république j'ai dit
qu'elle était ma dalton parce qu'elle
avait réussi à venir à bout d'avril
barnier et
de joey ciotti
et elle a répondu avec humour ah mais
non moi ça serait plutôt calamity jane
valérie pécresse est peut-être la plume
acronis que de toutes les candidates qui
était présente dans cette compétition
d'internât et l'air sec et en même temps
quasiment exactement le même profil qu
emmanuel macron elle a dit d'elle même
qu'elle était un tiers chaque chaire de
pierre merkel ce qui ne laisse pas grand
chose de bon je vais tout donner je vais
donner ma force je vais donner mon
énergie je vais donner ma détermination
traduit en français
ça vous donne deux termes accro à terre
j'ai moore la politique c'est pas des
boucs émissaires les mêmes que valérie
pécresse les immigrés les femmes les
homosexuels tout ça les donc on est dans
les fantasmes et on la recherche de bouc
et la candidate dlr a été élu avec
quelques dizaines de milliers de voix
autant que monsieur poisson qui était
candidat à l'époque à la primaire
interne c'est ça la réalité d'une droite
qui et rabougrie ker tracy et jean
frédéric poisson pourquoi avoir retiré
votre candidature eric zemmour est un
meilleur candidat que vous il nous
placer en tout cas il défend un projet
politique est similaire au mien nous
voulons dire
grande fois de plus dont la france ce
départ l'extrême droite
cette fois ce sont des militants anti
fascistes qui entendent sa beauté elle
l'événement ce midi des échauffourées
ont éclaté les forces de l'ordre étaient
déployées en nombre trente personnes ont
été
interpellées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fuir au plus vite voulu avoir ce nuage
de cendres de plusieurs kilomètres de
haut
[Musique]
oh mon dieu quinze mille français qui
ont bravé le politiquement correct les
menaces de l'extrême-gauche et la haine
des médias
sionistes de java le bilan de l'éruption
il hier du volcan c'est mary est passé à
13 morts les sauveteurs continuent à
fouiller la zone recouverte d'une
épaisse couche de cendres si je gagne
cette élection ce ne sera pas une
alternance de plus mais le début de la
reconquête du plus beau pays du monde
tous travaillent dans des boîtes et
petit bois des grandes boîtes mais pour
s'amuser on va en boîte enfin on y va
dans sa tête il ya la boîte où l'on met
les vieux en attendant la dernière boîte
que je vais je vous laisse deviner